life
and
changes
energy
one direction of
disease management
for passion
investment
energy efficiency
and vision of things to
energy
and finally
the
spider man show
di mediaset
energy mix transforming
today
was
born
again
mario
the
stars sex
is mario draghi
italian and buongiorno a tutti I want to
thank  president von der leyen
for this meeting and for the excellent
work done by her personally and by the
whole commission this week
the european union has shown
extraordinary
we are united in strongly condemning
the invasion of ukraine by the
russia
we are united in imposing sanctions
against moscow
and we are united in responding to
the appeal of ukrainian president ze lensky who
asked us for
military humanitarian financial aid to defend
against russian aggression
this unity also with the
NATO and g7 allies is  our main
essential strength to maintain it in dealing with
all consequences c  he this crisis
will have on the European Union such as
the reception of refugees from ukraine
the protection of
energy security for citizens and businesses
the government is fully committed to
seeking all diplomatic ways
to end the conflict
yesterday phoned the  president
of the ens chi to whom I reiterated the
solidarity of the government and the Italian people
in the next few days I will meet the
Polish prime minister and on Wednesday afternoon
or evening I think he knows a
telephone conversation with
Chancellor Sholes has been set
up Ukraine is part of the European family
and italy intends to continue to
support it
we are in contact with all the
main partners of the european union and with the
born and g7 in recent days
the financial security committee
of the ministry of the economy approved
important asset freezing measures
in the  confrontations of Russian oligarchs
which were promptly executed and
will continue to be executed  In the
coming days to the royal nile lightsey
analog seed the weapon gers been taken by
all art countries
the bank of Italy
has asked the credit institutions to
communicate the freezing measures
applied and to provide details on the
subjects involved and on the value and
nature of the assets
I want to thank the minister
of
the economy the bank of Italy the financial police
for the excellent work done so far
and now that with all of us with speed
contest
point Italy fully supports the
European Union also in the management of  migration crisis
this is the moment of solidarity and
hospitality
are founding values of the European Union and p
inciples that Italy has been putting into practice for y
ars on Ma
ch 3 we supported the historic appro
al of the implementation of the E
ropean directive on the tempo
ary protection of displaced persons in  benefit of
those fleeing the war in Ukraine
we have already allocated 110 million
to the Ukrainian government and we are
intervening p  e to help refugees with
financial aid and health materials
through the red cross civil protection
Italian cooperation we
will continue as always to do
our part also thanks to the work that
the interior ministry is doing
the prefectures that I have to thank in
particular the mayors of  many Italian municipalities
in today's talks as he told the
president to merge it in a moment ago we
will address the issues of energy we
will essentially discuss
diversification
reorganization and compensation to
protect citizens and
companies Italy is working to
quickly reduce dependence on  russian gas
saturday i heard on the phone the emir
of qatar al thani with whom i discussed
in particular about how to strengthen
energy cooperation between our
countries i want to thank the minister
cingolani who is here with me today
and the minister of maio for their
commitment  on this front we will
discuss this and other issues today
and at the info summit  rmale of Thursday and
Friday opponent thanks
good morning to all and goodbye